so we have a sum here of 2 plus 6 plus
18 plus 54 and we could obviously just
evaluate it add up these numbers but
what i want to do is i want to use it as
practice for rewriting a series like
this using sigma notation so let's just
think about what's happening here let's
see if we can see any pattern from one
term to the next let's see to go from
two to six we could say we're adding
four but then we go from six to eighteen
we're not adding four now we are now
adding twelve so it's not an arithmetic
series
let's see what of maybe it's a geometric
so to go from two to six what are we
doing well we're multiplying by we're
multiplying by three
so let me write that
we're multiplying by 3 to go to 6 to 18
what are we doing well we're multiplying
by 3 to go to 18 to 54. we're
multiplying by 3. so it looks like this
in this is indeed a geometric series and
we have a common ratio of 3. so let's
rewrite this using sigma notation so
this is going to be the sum
and we could start well there's a bunch
of ways that we could write it we could
write it as let's start with k
equaling 0.
and so we have our first term which is 2
so it's 2
times our common ratio to the kth power
so times our common ratio 3 to the k
power so before i even write how many
terms we have here or how high we go
with our k let's see if this makes sense
when k is equal to 0 there's going to be
2 times 3 to the 0th power so that's 2
times 1 so that's this first term right
there when k is equal to 1 it'll be 2
times 3 to the first power well that's
going to be 6.
and then when k is so this is k equals 0
let me just in a different color so this
is k
equals 0. i say different color and then
i do the same color
all right
so this is k equals zero this is k
equals one
this is k equals two and then this would
be k equals three which would be two
times
three to the third power so two times 27
is indeed equal to 54. so we're going to
go up to k is
k is equal to 3. so that's one way that
we could write this
there's other ways that you could write
this you could write it as
so we're going to still do we have our
first term right over here but for
example we could write it as
our common ratio and i'll use a
different index now let's say to the n
minus one power
and instead of starting at zero i could
start at n equals one but notice it has
the same effect when you say n equals 1
it's 1 minus 1 you get the 0th power and
so we're just in we're increasing all of
the
indexes by 1. so instead of going from 0
to 3 we're going from 1 to 4. and you
could verify that this is still going to
work out because when n is equal to 4
it's 3 to the 4 minus 1 power so it's
still 3 to the third power which is 27
times 2 which is still 54. so this is n
equals
1 that is n equals 2
that is n equals 3 and that is n equals
4. but either way these are ways that
you could write it using sigma notation